if you're creating vertical video assets
you could be sharing those across
multiple platforms you're doing YouTube
shorts or YouTube's blowing up but one
of the other places where it's going
crazy for you is on Facebook what
happened I just got a notification on my
Facebook you've been invited to join
professional mode what it does is it
just basically turns your personal
profile into like business light I just
used the top performing videos they were
working really well for me on Tick Tock
and it started to build momentum wow and
so what were the results of your growth
and followership right now I'm at 770
000 followers I'm gaining about 170 000
followers a month right now because
organic reach is 19.5 million yeah wow
great see